oscar-winning director Leo McCarey was
in a bank he was trying to borrow some
money for a picture so sizing him up the
banker said you know I know what a
camera man does he runs the camera
actors act writers write what does a
director do well Leo paused and then he
went to another Bank the truth is the
director does everything imaginable to
realize a singular vision these five
such visionaries have been nominated for
their exemplary work here are the
nominees for achievement in directing
Michelle asada B shoes the artist
Alexander Payne the descendants Martin
Scorsese Hugo Woody Allen Midnight in
Paris Terrence Malick the Tree of Life
and the Oscar goes to me she'll have an
issue
this is the third Academy Award
nomination tonight for Michel
Hazanavicius and his first Oscar
yes thank you thank you very much I have
a note card
I forgot my speech okay I am the
happiest director in the world right now
thank you for that thank you the Academy
thank you all of you I want to thank my
beloved producer Thomas Lang man thank
you
I want to thank the other Winston
company okay I want to thank the the
cast Jean Pyrenees you know thank you
James James Cromwell John Goodman missi
pyle Penelope all of you
Malcolm Magda well thank you very much I
want to thank all the crew I want to
thank again the dog I think he doesn't
care
I'm not sure you understand what I say
is not that good but thank you I want to
thank the financial the crazy person who
put money in that movie I want to thank
the people who helped that movie like
chief mo or pol Rossum Robert thank you
and also I want to thank the movie
because the movies since this movie has
been made it's his life is full of grace
and it brings to us joy and happiness
and and sometime life is wonderful and
today is one of these day thank you for
giving it to me thank you very much
thank you